Libertarian Party presidential hopeful
Jacob Hornberger has a message for
Americans under 40 right now the
government's taken out of your paycheck
two trillion dollars a year just for
Medicare and Social Security I'm saying
bull keep your money
cut out the middleman I trust you to
handle this on your own
Hornberger is the new frontrunner in the
race for the lp nomination following the
withdrawal of Congressman Justin Amash
and he's running on a platform that
straightforward concise and doctrinaire
he unapologetically stands for open
immigration free trade an end to non
defensive military interventions the
legalization of all drugs and the
replacement of the income tax and the
IRS with voluntary payments to fund the
government
I talked with Hornberger of I assume
about the role of the libertarian party
what he would do as president and how
his unconventional beliefs about history
inform his platform
Jacob Hornberger thanks for talking with
reason oh thanks for mine it's an honor
and a pleasure to be here with you Nick
great so you know let's start why do you
want to be President I want to live in a
free society I want everyone to live in
a free society when I discovered
libertarianism at 28 years of age I was
a young lawyer in my hometown of Laredo
in it it came as a shock to me all my
life I'd been taught that I was in a
free society and pledge allegiance in
the public schools I'd attended and so
forth with liberty and justice for all
and here I'm discovering a philosophy
that says you're not free at all and it
would add what year what year was that
so your family a 1978 okay and your your
coming out your you lived in Texas in
Laredo your whole life where you're what
were your parents what did they do and
were they Democrats Republicans old-time
conservatives or Yellow Dog Democrats I
guess that would have been in play back
in Texas well at that time everybody was
a Democrat I mean it was a rare thing to
be a Republican in Texas in 1978 and my
dad was active in Democratic Party
politics he had come from San Antonio
where he was born and raised and and
came down to Laredo for a temporary time
and met my mother and fell in love and
decided to stay
and my mother was a housewife her
parents had emigrated from Mexico from
Passos and from Monterey Mexico and when
I grew up it was with the Democratic
Party I campaigned for Lyndon Johnson
and John Kennedy in the fifth grade I
went to the Johnson ranch for a
political rally with my dad in the
Laredo delegation I shook hands with
Lyndon Johnson himself and so it was a
democratic my dad was mostly a
conservative Democrat but he that's the
way I grew up
in Loretto as a as a I I became a
Liberal Democrat until I discovered
libertarianism yes so you and in your
most recent book you talk about your
kind of conversion narrative how did you
become a libertarian then yeah III was a
Democrat I believe that the government
served a useful and valuable function in
helping the poor I was on the legal aid
board of trustees for the local Legal
Aid Society which provided free legal
assistance to the poor I was the ACLU
representative in Laredo and then I
ambled into the public library in
Loretto one day and I find these four
little books called essays on liberty
that had been published by the
foundation for economic education some
20 years before and I started thumbing
through them and it was a road to
Damascus experience I was just stunned
by what I was reading
what what what stood out you don't
because then I'm thinking of you know
when you're talking about being a
liberal Democrat in context as' and the
South more broadly was maybe not in the
late 70s but in your childhood have been
pretty conservative if you were working
for the ACLU that meant that you
believed in racial equality you probably
believe that women units deserved equal
rights to men and all sorts of things
like that what did the libertarian kind
of philosophies what itch did that
scratch that wasn't being covered by you
know Democratic Party politics in in
deep deep in Texas well you're right
about the ACLU I mean what attracted me
today so you was this ardent devotion to
civil liberties you know I was a lawyer
and when they when they
had their their defense of the Nazi
protesters in Skokie Alice Koki Illinois
that is so deeply impressed me that here
was an outfit that standing on principle
with a big price but their economics
just kind of bothered me and and then
when I discovered these four little
bucks the big thing in which is the
driving one of the driving forces in my
campaign here was the welfare state way
of life and that the very thing that I
had favored that government exists to
help the poor the needy seniors Social
Security Medicare Medicaid Franklin
Roosevelt's New Deal Lyndon Johnson's
Great Society and at that point I
learned that if I ever am going to live
in a free society I have to get this
dismantle the whole welfare state way of
life that these books were book essays
by Ludwig von Mises Leonard read that
made the moral case that it's for
freedom that is wrong for the government
to take money from one group of people
and give it to another group of people
that that's not charity it's just
political stealing and that's at that
moment I learned that if you want a free
society you have to challenge the system
and its fundamentals if you buy into
Social Security and Medicare which are
the crown jewels and which two of my
principle opponents in this race favor
you've given away the store you've got
to go head-on and make the case to the
American people that this was a horrible
system we had the finest economic system
in history based on economic Liberty the
concept of economic Liberty people keep
everything they earn no IRS no income
tax no Social Security no Medicare no
welfare state it produced the greatest
standard of living in history and the
most charitable nation in history all
voluntarily the welfare state
revolutionized American society and it
destroyed our freedom and that's why
when I entered this race I made it very
clear I want to run a campaign of
principle that goes after Democrats and
Republicans on their welfare state as
well as course the national security
state which is a whole different subject
but you can't live in a free society as
long as you live in an init and a
welfare state okay so I I want to get to
you're kind of thumbnail critiques of
Trump and Joe Biden as well as run
through some of the main issues and your
campaign platform I just want to finish
this early kind of the early Jacob
Hornberger story you were against the
welfare state you also talked in a
location that used to be used much more
commonly in the in the late 60s and
early 70s
you're also against the warfare state
but you also have served in uniform what
did you do in the military and also when
did you realize that the warfare state
was also as problematic as the welfare
state all right I went to you to college
after graduating from high school in in
Laredo and I'd grown up on a farm on the
Rio Grande and so it was an unusual way
of life you know I became an expert in
baling hay and selling hey there on our
farm we had a horse and cows and wild
hogs and stuff but I graduated from high
school in Laredo went to college at
Virginia Military Institute my dad had
said look you know you really ought to
consider going to this school you the
probability is you're going to end up in
Vietnam you want to be well-trained
you're going to get a good education
here and so I did that well I didn't mix
well with the military structure at VMI
I didn't know anything about
libertarianism or individualism but man
the military structure there did not get
along well all the rules and the
regimentation I mean to me when people
ask me today what you learn at VMI and I
said well I got a great education they
got me into law school no question about
that but I also learned what it's like
to live under a socialist fascist
society where you know justice is
arbitrary and tyrannical where the
state's taking care of you where they
know where you are every minute and it
made me realize how much I appreciate a
free society because a military school
is the opposite of a free society okay I
spent four years there though and I
graduate and I'm a happy man when I
graduated and so I'm going to law school
at this point but I get commissioned I'm
a commissioned officer in the Army I was
an infantry officer and I knew what I
was doing I mean I was in the Ranger
unit at VMI Rangers are your elite
military
a component in any school or in the in
the military itself so I go to law
school and halfway through I drop out to
attend infantry school at Fort Benning
Georgia three months well I've got an
eight year Reserve commitment and so I
did those three months which were not
the most pleasant months in my life and
doing infantry school in Colombia
Georgia Columbus Georgia so then I go to
Dallas and I wait tables at the glory
hole mine company and and in Dallas to
get the money to pay the rest of my
schooling which was about you know it's
semester and a half left so I returned
to law school
and then returned to Laredo and
interestingly enough they forgot about
me in the military I mean they kept me
what was called a control group so I
never had to go to meetings I never had
to go to a summer camp until my seventh
year my eighth year commitment I got
orders to report to the quartermaster
unit in Laredo so I had to do one year
of monthly meetings there that they
never they never made me go to summer
camp because I had an active law
practice and I told him that I said like
I got trials and stuff every you know
the whole time so then the eighth year
they let me out of the last year of
commitment so I only ended up spending
three months on active duty plus one
month and they're in the active reserves
well I was it's a good way to get out of
serving in Vietnam so while being
patriotic let's let me point out there
Vietnam when I graduate see my first two
years advant in mine I was it was clear
that we were all going to Vietnam and
you know they wouldn't make
announcements in the mess hall sometimes
on people that were killed in action
that were VMI grads and it was a somber
time it I'll never forget those
announcements but my senior year was 72
and Nixon's pulling the troops out of
Vietnam at this point and and then so
they had a two-year active-duty
commitment they walked into our military
science class one day and said anybody
here want to trade an eight-year Kamiya
two-year commitment for eight years in
the reserves and my arm practically came
out of my socket Soviet Vietnam was
winding down by the time I graduated
I also should point out that I believe
in the Vietnam War for the first two
years and then I realized what a
Crockett was my junior year and that's
when I turned against the war as did
many VMI cadets well you know we're
gonna talk about foreign policy and just
a second
let's before we get to Biden and Trump
in your platform let's talk about
coronavirus the corona virus pandemic
and the response to it because you know
that that is going to dominate the news
between now and who knows when which
what's your sense of the corona virus
locked down and you know ardh local
state and federal governments doing this
right or are they wrong how would it be
different if you were in office well I
take a different perspective on this I
go back to fundamentals that you know in
1994 I wrote a book called a day our
published a book called the dangers of
socialized medicine my work at the
future freedom foundation which I should
emphasize does not endorse my candidacy
and and we have always made the argument
that in order to resolve the health care
crisis and we have to remember that it's
been a health care crisis long before
coronavirus that you've got to get
government entirely out of health care
and that specifically means Medicare and
Medicaid which distinguishes me from at
least two of the opponents in this race
that's the root cause of the soaring
healthcare costs when I was growing up
in Loretto before Medicare and Medicaid
health care costs were like going to the
grocery store nobody had major medical
insurance because they didn't need it
doctors gave free health care to people
in laredo poor people we lived in the
poorest city in the United States they
gave it away free then they never turned
away anyone same same way with Mercy
Hospital a Catholic hospital in Laredo
this is the this is what my ideal of a
health care system is where people are
doing things voluntarily so then you've
got this coronavirus crisis that has
expose the other aspect of this
socialist system and and Medicare and
Medicaid or socialist programs and that
central planning that you've got the
Centers for Disease Control you've got
the FDA you got the president's task
force you got the Health and Human
Services central planning as you know
Nick is a central construct of socialist
and it's so central planning always
produces this kind of chaos that we see
going on shortages mass ventilators and
stuff same thing happened in the Soviet
Union which was based on central
planning you've got planned chaos as
Ludwig von Mises would call it and
underneath that the foundation these
socialist programs Medicare and Medicaid
well when this system doesn't work and
it clearly doesn't work that's when they
turn to tyranny and oppression same
thing happened in the Soviet Union
that's where the lockdowns come in the
arrests the threats the the handcuffing
and so forth what I'm bringing to this
race is saying let's build the
foundation for a permanently healthy
health care system by separating health
care entirely from the state get rid of
Medicare and Medicaid which would cause
health care cost a plummet down to low
and reasonable levels you get rid of the
central planning you have a dynamic
free-market health care system the free
market produces the best of everything
if we'd have a healthcare free-market
health care system right now we would be
looking to the healthcare industry for
guidance on getting out of this thing we
wouldn't have politicians and
bureaucrats who are showing their little
inner tyrants and inner dictatorships so
what I want to bring to this race is a
higher vision for the American people of
how do we build the foundation for a
free society and a healthy society as
compared to saying let me show you how
I'm gonna run their dysfunctional system
because when you've got an inherently
defective system doesn't matter who's in
charge I would say but I'd you know just
specifically I'd say the novel
coronavirus do you agree that there
should be mandatory lock downs or that
some businesses should be shut down
until some you know level of public
safety can be reasonably ascertained or
things like that you know and that's
what I'm saying this is all tyranny and
oppression that you've got to get the
state totally out of this thing this is
a natural disaster it's no different
from a hurricane or normally you know
and I think you know people like iron
Rand and I suspect even Mises would say
you know in the wake of a hurricane or
of a you know a flood there might be a
period where the government comes in and
says okay we're coordinate
now you say no categorically or no in
this particular instance no
categorically the free market is the
greatest answer to these kind of crises
and get rid of all the anti gouging laws
the government's bring to this thing
that you know you you let the free
market provide the bottled water that
needs to come in they can make big money
big prices that's the way price this
price system works get government out of
these natural disasters and let the free
market operate well let's let's talk now
about Donald Trump first and then we'll
talk about Joe Biden the presumptive
Democratic nominee for president Donald
Trump what is your you know and we we
don't have an infinite amount of time
but you know make a brief case why is
Donald Trump a bad president because he
stands for a bad system a bad philosophy
and and we can lump Joe Biden and and
Donald Trump into the same answer
because they both stand for the same
thing they stand for this welfare state
way of life they stand for the warfare
state way of life the national security
state they stand for immigration
controls they stand for the drug war in
other words their entire system is the
problem I have no interest in going
after Donald Trump for being a bad
person or what he's done in his personal
life to me that is totally irrelevant
and that's the way I've run this
campaign within the party I've
instructed my campaign team this will be
issues only never any personal attacks
we're gonna run a first-class campaign
win or lose and that's the kind of
campaign that run against Trump and
Biden that I've said this repeatedly
I've said I want to run a campaign of
principles ideas and sound ideas on
Liberty because they're not accustomed
to that that's their weak point they
can't answer when I challenge them on
their welfare state on their drug war on
their immigration controls they can't
handle that kind of challenge because
they don't know how to respond so
there's really for you there is no
meaningful difference between Donald
Trump and Joe Biden absolutely not
they're one party divided into two wings
the welfare warfare party let's say you
manage you you get the lp nomination
which is you know will be unfolding over
the next couple of weeks
and you you somehow you you become
president how do you work with either
you know how do you work with Congress
because you're saying that these you
know the representatives of these
parties are both the same thing they
don't think that but you know and that
they're both completely so awful that
you you know you have to overthrow them
is is there any way that you can be an
effective leader if you're running on
the principles that you're running
absolutely I mean because you can do a
lot as president regardless of where
they stand you can lift all the
executive orders that impose sanctions
on foreign countries that are targeting
innocent people like Iran these are a
moral abomination you rescind those
executive orders you can pardon all
nonviolent offenders in the federal
system especially drug offenders but
Edward Snowden Julian Assange you can
order the Secretary of Defense which I
would do to bring all troops home from
everywhere Korea Europe World War twos
over Iraq Middle East Afghanistan Africa
Latin America bring him home and
discharge that's another thing that
distinguishes me from my opponents say
they want the troops to come over and
stay and become this giant military
establishment I would discharge him the
pricey and the debt ceiling when that
debt ceiling comes up I wouldn't cave
like Donald Trump would I would stand
there firm and say if you can't live
within your means yep this government's
going to have to shut down or at least
the non-essential functions now then you
do then you you get probably pressure on
them to like repeal the drug war because
I think that's teetering you get people
to email them telephone calls I mean
Congress responds to public pressure and
then if they don't respond in a positive
way you start running libertarians two
years later for Congress all across land
you run libertarians in every single
congressional race and you you'd let the
American people know start sprinkling
Congress here with some libertarians so
we can bring freedom to this country by
pushing Democrats and Republicans in the
right direction so you you've kind of
given away the the preview of some of
your issues but let's let's run through
your platform
and uh you know I'm gonna throw out some
topics or planks and explain to me what
your preferred policies are and you know
your website I'm sorry it's uh is it
Jacob what what is your your website
Jacob for liberty comm okay
and your platform is a marvel of
straightforwardness and concision not a
lot of extra words or camouflage going
on free trade how do you define free
trade and what did what's your position
on free trade it's the freedom of people
to trade that whatever they own buy and
sell without any government restriction
whatsoever so I favor unilateral free
trade no negotiations with any foreign
power the president my opinion is not a
designated elected agent for American
businessmen American businessmen can
handle their own deals just drop all
restrictions tariffs draw a unilaterally
drop president Trump's trade war against
China so destructive of not only
economic prosperity but also Liberty I
mean that's what these trade
restrictions are they are an
infringement on Liberty I would have
just unilateral dismantling of every
single trade restriction because how do
you yeah how do you respond to you know
the criticism which we hear a lot from
both Donald Trump talked about this in
2016 we'll be talking about it again Joe
Biden the Democrats particularly
factions within the Democratic Party
that are affiliated with trade unions
they say look you know what we had free
trade with places like China where you
know we're taking there you know we're
allowing them to sell here cheap they
put up tariffs on their is that's why
Americans are out of work you know
what's wrong with that critique of free
trade well it's so amazing that we still
have this debate I mean you know Adam
Smith's comes up with his treatise on
economics in 1776 and you've got the
classical economists and Frederic
Bastiat making the case for free trade
to me it's amazing that we're still
having to debate these things with these
Democrats and Republicans in every trade
both sides benefit and and that's just
an axiom because you give up something
you value less for something you value
more so the corollary of that is that
any restriction on trade is interfering
with your ability to raise your standard
of living you can raise your standard of
living just do trade by giving up so are
you saying and you know just to work
through the logic let's say China puts a
hundred percent tariff on you know
American car is being sold in China we
don't have any tariffs on that and the
government subsidizes a Chinese car so
that it's sold safe you know for $100
the effective price of an American car
being sold in China is say five hundred
dollars you are you're good with that
and you just say that people will sort
things out regardless of China you know
the government they're really kind of
putting its thumb on the scale in favor
of its local producers well I'm never
good with any restrictions I mean what
the Chinese government is doing is
really hurting the Chinese people
because the tariff is a tax on them is
not really a tax on Americans so let's
say we have a total free trade policy
here and a foreign regime let's use
China imposes a high tariff a tax on the
Chinese people let's say that they even
subsidize cars thereby taxing the the
Chinese people and so they can provide
hundred-dollar cars for Americans we
benefit from that
I mean if Japan all a sudden offered
everybody a hundred dollar Toyota
Corolla I mean everybody would love it
well that's hurting the Chinese people
the worst thing that America can do is
retaliate by shooting themselves in the
foot by saying okay you're having these
things we're going to impose these
things on the American people just keep
the American people free and let the
Chinese people see the virtues of free
trade and ultimately repeal their
restrictions if they don't well that
just means Americans have to work
American business women have to work
around those restrictions but don't
retaliate by taking away our freedom in
our prosperity here at home you know a
compliment to free trade is immigration
the and you are an open borders advocate
that's a phrase which you know in
libertarian circles generally speaking I
think most libertarians are in favor of
the free movement of people goods and
services across borders some some
libertarians are not I want to get to
that in a sec
what is your what's your position on
immigration what should the u.s.
immigration policy be open immigration
abolish the Immigration Service the ice
the Border Patrol abolish all
restrictions on the free movements of
goods people and services the same way
we have domestically I mean if you want
to have an idea of what I favor look at
domestically people are free to cross
state borders without any restriction
that's what I favor in terms of so there
wouldn't even be in a Hornberger United
States there would not even be something
like an Ellis Island where you come
through and say who you are and get some
kind of ID number and get checked for a
communicable disease it would just be
like you know I'm talking to you from
New York City I'm just gonna drive
across the George Washington Bridge into
New Jersey no checkpoints no anything
exactly we don't have an Ellis Island
between Texas and you know New Mexico
and so why should there be an Ellis
Island you know between Mexico and the
United States in fact when Ellis Island
was working where they were trying to
ferret out people who had tuberculosis
in the American Southwest my home land
there was no restrictions at all
especially after the Treaty of Guadalupe
Hidalgo people were free to cross back
and forth there was no stations at all
same on the west coast people were
coming from China and Japan for more
than a hundred years this was our
heritage is the greatest immigration
system in history what uh what do you
say to fellow libertarians and I and I'm
thinking of people like Ron Paul and you
you have the backing or the support of
the von mises or the Mises Institute
kind of wing of the libertarian party
oftentimes people like Ron Paul when he
was in Congress he was against NAFTA
he was against a lot of free trade
agreements saying they weren't really
free trade but the net effect was to you
know keep trade barriers in place
they're also often skeptical of
immigration and particularly of the open
immigration that you're talking about
where are they going wrong with you know
with their analysis do you think I think
they're going wrong with respect to
holding on to what was really is
Republican baggage
this is where Republicans are different
from from libertarians well and
Democrats to you know Republicans often
say that Democrats favor open borders
it's nonsense I mean this is one of the
precipitating that the preed when I when
I discovered libertarianism one of the
things I first experienced to make me
wonder about Democrats who as I was in a
detention center representing illegal
immigrants as a lawyer and I dawned on
me I said how can Democrats love the
poor needy and disadvantaged when
they're jailing people who want to work
and so they're the only people who favor
open borders are libertarians it and
we're guided by the libertarian
non-aggression principle that is that it
is wrong to initiate force against
peaceful human beings and peaceful human
activity when you cross a political
border you're not violating anybody's
rights and when government initiates
force against you it's violating your
rights and this is where the pro
immigration control libertarians and the
and the right the Republicans and
Democrats they just don't see that and
here's the other aspect if they don't
see with a immigration control system
comes a police state I grew up in this
police they'd have had first-hand
experience I've been stopped by the
Border Patrol just randomly open up your
trunk
they've got fixed highway checkpoints on
my farm the Border Patrol
could come on into my form without a
warrant and and they bust we hired
illegal immigrants and they busted our
workers because they had the authority
to get down to the river my farm was
located on the river Rio Grande this is
not a free society this this is a police
state and it comes with an immigration
control system just as Thunder comes
with lightning it is kind of relieving
to hear a presidential candidate
actually openly acknowledge that they
hired illegal immigrants Donald Trump
you know obviously has done it at his
properties but kind of slough sit away
and Joe Biden pretends you know that
he's never done anything wrong
how do you you know the federal budget
before for 2020 fiscal 2020 before the
coronavirus stuff happened was coming in
around four point eight trillion dollars
how much should the government you know
let's let's leave aside any
anything about coronavirus what should
the government be spending for the
federal government be spending per year
and how do you pay for it in your in
your scheme well I favor a limited
government Republic that's our founding
governmental system that's why I oppose
the national security state type of
governmental system that that's been the
biggest mistake America ever made and if
you support a national security state
then you can kiss your your hope of a
free society away and then there's the
welfare state which we've talked about
if you dismantle the whole welfare state
programs with Roosevelt and Johnson and
the whole panoply of welfare state
programs and then you dismantle the
national security state CIA NSA pentagon
military-industrial complex and you end
up with a limited government republic
that has just a basic military force to
protect the United States you're talking
about ninety five percent of government
expenditures gone you don't need an
income tax
you don't need an IRS because you don't
have the Department of Agriculture
Energy Commerce Health and Human
Services Homeland Security you don't
have any of these I think you end up
maybe with a Department of the Treasury
Attorney General Justice Department
Secretary of State and that's pretty
much about it
that doesn't you and you send all
criminal jurisdiction to the states and
state district attorneys there's no
expenditures last you have a febrile
judiciary that's handling civil lawsuits
you're talking about minuscule minuscule
government expenditures how do you pay
for it how do you pay for that is that
through service fees or what I mean
what's what
there's no IRS and a Hornberger
administration but what do you do for
the for the the few pennies that the the
government needs how do you raise well
the framers answer for this type of
minimal government was what they called
indirect taxes they hated the idea of a
direct tax like like an income tax
because it's so intrusive and the
Internal Revenue Service is such a
tyrannical agency so if you pay a sales
tax or something like that it's less
intrusive for me so I and I agree with
that
much less intrusive for me the
initiation of force can never be morally
justified and so I would favor a
voluntarily funded government that
people believe in government most people
do they believe in the police to protect
them from robbers and murderers and
rapists
people we rely on people to support
churches hospitals libraries charitable
organizations reason magazine I think
you would have absolutely no problem
generating voluntarily sabalan Terry
support for government at all levels
federal government state level and in
local government that's my ideal and I
think the freest Society in history one
of these days is going to be a limited
government Republic voluntarily funded
we've talked a bit or touched on some
issues about war and kind of the deep
state the national surveillance that our
national security state how do you
differ from a typical democratic or
republican candidate when it comes to
war making and towards national defense
I oppose all foreign interventionism i
America was founded on a foreign policy
of non-intervention ISM and that's in
John Quincy Adams great speech in search
of monsters to destroy that he delivered
to Congress on the 4th of July in 1821
just and all foreign interventionism
abandon all foreign military bases lift
all sanctions bring all those troops
home discharge them because you don't
need them anymore
you've stopped foreign interventionism
entirely you then you that's not even
enough though for a free society this
again is what distinguishes made from
some of my opponents to get a free
society you've got to get rid of this
national security cold war-era state and
that includes the NSA the CIA and the
vast what Eisenhower called a
military-industrial complex where you
have just a basic military force that's
able to protect the United States garner
support in case the United States was
ever invaded which is a virtually
non-existent possibility now compare
that to what Biden and Trump stand for
they stand for the CIA the NSA the vast
military-industrial complex the garrison
state which is the opposite of a free
society
in in your worldview does America have
allies I mean you know trading partners
and things like that and what do you do
say with a country like Taiwan which is
an ally and military and commercial ally
of the United States constantly kind of
being threatened by China
if mainland China of Communist China
moves into Taiwan we say it was nice
knowing you but we're gonna we're gonna
work with your new overlords how do you
how do you respond to that kind of
provocation George Washington gave the
the soundest advice when he says no
entangling alliances that the US
government should just stay here at home
and tend to its own business do not be a
world's policeman because this is John
Quincy Adams said in that speech as soon
as America goes abroad to police these
types of things she becomes the dictator
of the world and then we lose our
freedom here at home because of all the
threats then that America faces but
that's not to say that individual
Americans should not be free to go to
Taiwan and fight on behalf of the
Taiwanese or the South Koreans or the
South Vietnamese if somebody's outraged
over what's happening overseas go over
there take up arms and join the cause
but keep the federal government out of
the process you you have written in the
past some provocative things that I want
to touch on them because they factor
into this you've written that FDR that
that essentially that the United States
is responsible for the Japanese bombing
of Pearl Harbor and effectively that F T
that the the received narrative that
Japan attacked the United States
declared war on the United States Nazi
Germany declared war on the United
States we go into World War two you
actually have written suggesting that
FDR goaded Japan into attacking us
what's going on there well there's no
question about it even Roosevelt
apologists say that he did the right
thing and wanting to get the United
States into the war and there's no
question
historians all agree now that he wanted
to get the United States and or
absolutely but isn't that different I
mean it's one thing to say that we were
going to get embroiled into it and and
we want to get in on our own terms or as
quickly as possible in saying that
how FDR is really responsible for the
bombing of Pearl Harbor well when you
say responsible we're talking about
directly or indirectly obviously the
Bombers are the ones responsible for
dropping the bombs and Japan's
responsible for ordering the bombs to be
dropped but you have to put things in
context because there's nuances taking
place here that Roosevelt knew that
around 90% of the American people after
the debacle of World War one did not
want to enter into World War two so this
was when presidents will still we're
still honoring the declaration of war
requirement in the Constitution he knew
he could not get a declaration of war so
he had to figure out a way to get into
this war and so he go to Germany and to
try and to attacking American ships and
in the Atlantic Germany refuses to take
the bait they they didn't want another
US entry into the war after World War
one so he goes into the Pacific is sort
of a backdoor to war look what he does
he freezes all Japanese bank accounts
we're not at war with with the US wasn't
at war with with Japan he he imposes an
oil embargo that was surprisingly
effective of involving different
countries well here's he knows that
Japan has his war machine going on in
China it needs that oil and then he he
when when did you pan said let's
negotiate
Roosevelt imposes these humiliating jet
on terms of which are mounted
essentially to a surrender he knew they
would never accept it so we look at
Pearl Harbor
he's got ships all there ready to be
bombed
he leaves troops in the Philippines I
mean what her troops doing in the
Philippines that's like that's not even
the United States and and everything
pointed he had broken the Japanese
civilian code so he knew that that what
the war clouds were brewing he doesn't
give the warning directly to the
commanders in Pearl every all the
circumstantial evidence points to now
there's no flashing a smoking gun here
but the circumstantial evidence points
to that he was trying to provoke
Japanese the Japanese into attacking
somewhere Philippines didn't really
matter where so that he could then go to
Congress and say well we
men attack these vadas that is a
controversial take and one I ate I can't
go there with you I when you look at
expansionist Imperial Japan they didn't
need a lot of reasons to kind of try and
strike out let's jump though to relate
thing about that okay they didn't need
to attack Pearl Harbor and they weren't
invading the United States there was no
reason to start a war with the United
States they needed oil and they were
going into the Dutch East Indies to get
that oil and they figured if they could
knock out the Pacific Fleet that they
would be able to get their oil unimpeded
that's why they attacked there if
Roosevelt had never done these master
nations they never would have attacked
the United States they would have just
gone to the duchies yeah you know and
then we get into a long conversation
which I'm not sure how fruitful it would
be what would the world look like you
know under an alliance of Japan and Nazi
Germany and a few other countries etc
can we jump to a more an equally I think
controversial claim that you make you've
written a number of books about the JFK
assassination and you've held some
conferences you fold in people like
Oliver Stone the filmmaker and other
people who say that JFK was obviously he
was assassinated he was killed but that
he was not killed by Lee Harvey Oswald
he was killed by the deep state what is
what's your basic argument there and how
does that inform the way that you think
about your run for presidency well it it
forced my my view with respect to the
national security state when President
Eisenhower left the White House he
delivered his farewell address where he
said this way of life the national
security state is an alien way of life
it's it's a grave threat to our
democratic processes and our in our
liberties and and this is what he's
referred to as the dangers of a giant
military intelligence establishment here
and it if I could just point out because
I my father fought in World War two so I
take a great interest in it and it is
nothing short of amazing that Eisenhower
in 1960 you know 15 years after world
war ii the the leader the you know of
our effort of the world's effort is
calling out a military-industrial
complex and the idea of standing armies
and merchants of death
it is pretty stunning and I think we've
in many ways have lost exactly what that
means but oh it's nominal and then 30
days after the JFK assassination
President Truman or former President
Truman publishes an op-ed in the
Washington Post saying that the CIA has
become a sinister force in American life
and that we need to look at this that
could not have been a quince who killed
in your in your understanding of things
who killed Kennedy the deep state okay
be more specific that what does that
mean and did Lee Harvey Oswald actually
pull a trigger that day or as he as he
liked to claim was was he a patsy and
again you know can you can you bring
this rather than talking about the JFK
assassination which as a country we've
been doing for you know over half a
century how does this inform what you
would how you would act as president
well because it shows the the dangers of
a national security state way of life
because you see their job is to protect
national security now what happens if a
president becomes a threat to national
security well remember the CIA's got the
power to assassinate people they have a
power to assassinate Americans fully
confirmed by the federal judiciary they
they make the call on what's a threat to
national security this is why a national
security state form of government is so
dangerous and they have assassinated
Americans and based on national security
so here john kennedy comes into office
is your standard cold warrior he
immediately gets in a huge fight with
battle war with the CIA over the Bay of
Pigs and then he gets in a war with the
that with the military over the refusal
to invade Cuba they had operation
Northwoods that they wanted the
President to do pursue which was a
fraudulent scheme to invade Cuba well
then the Cuban Missile Crisis comes
along and both the CIA and the military
exhorting him to attack Cuba invade Cuba
he refuses to do so much to everybody's
happiness afterward because it turned
out he would have been an all-out
nuclear war because what the CIA and the
military didn't know is that the Soviet
commanders had what fully armed nuclear
weapons with battlefield authority to
you
them so Kennedy strikes a deal with the
Soviets where he really gave away the
store I mean he said I will guarantee
that you will never that we will never
invade Cuba and he gave his word on that
what well that immediately made him a
threat to national security because
everyone knew in the military-industrial
complex in the CIA that Cuba was a grave
threat to national security that America
could not survive with this communist
dagger well then at this point Kennedy
has broken through all the Cold War
crock that was going on he realized it
was just a racket so he goes to American
University without even telling the
Pentagon and the CIA what he's going to
do he announces an end of the Cold War
unilateral he says this is this is a
racket I'm finishing it I'm going to
establish peaceful coexistence with the
Soviets with the Communist world we can
get along we have different ideologies
the speech was broadcast all across the
Soviet Union at that moment he becomes a
threat to national security
just like Mossadegh in 1953 was a threat
to national security so who signs the
order what uh you know what part of the
government what part of the deeps that
is responsible for Kennedy's
assassination there is no smoking gun as
to who exactly was involved but you know
it's it's the same as let's say a regime
change operation in Guatemala in 54 or
in and we didn't did as well pull the
trigger like was it his shots that
killed Kennedy or is it did did those
bullets come from someplace else they
came from somewhere else I mean this guy
says he says what's fascinating about
Oswald
he didn't just deny doing this I mean
that would be the the simple reaction is
hey I didn't do this I have nothing to
do with this he went one step further he
said I've been framed here now why would
he go that far why would he say I've
been framed well yeah it's partly
because he was caught and he knew he was
going to be tried and executed but no no
it's not that easy because if you get
caught you deny you do it if you say
you've been framed they're gonna say who
framed you then now you've got a new
burden that you've assumed so he clearly
has somebody in mind
takes this position and now my books
deal with the autopsy I don't know if
you've read Doug horns five volume book
on the autopsy but that's the definitive
case of what happened in the autopsy and
that's how you learn that the deep state
was involved in the assassination right
because it's clearly a fraudulent
autopsy so I mean you know what the that
you're kind of your read of World War
two and of FDR's actions there as well
as the Kennedy assassination lead you to
wanting to dismantle or get rid of
national security state deep state
things like that let's talk about some
of your other platform planks or
positions and we can go through these I
think a little bit more quickly but
you've you've mentioned that you're
against the drug war why are you against
the drug war should you and and you are
not simply against the idea that people
who are using marijuana should not be
criminals you talk about getting rid of
all laws about drugs how'd it have what
that work yeah because again I want a
free society Nick I want to live in a
free society that's what I decided when
I was 28 years old when I discovered
libertarianism and that takes certain
prerequisites if we're gonna live in a
free society you got to get rid of the
welfare state including Social Security
Medicare you leave those and you don't
live in a free society you got to get
rid of the national security state you
can leave those you're not living in a
free society and the drug war essential
aspect of individual liberty is the
right to ingest whatever you want to
ingest I don't care how destructive
harmful dangerous it is so you support
Donald Trump's right to take
hydroxychloroquine whether it works or
not
and that's one thing you can agree on he
should be able to to take whatever he
wants of course I mean that's the the
the mark of a free society is being
stupid if you would you would you also
you would get rid of prescription drugs
in the sense that the there should be no
centralized control of saying this drug
is only available if you you know if you
get a doctor who is certified by the
state who says you can you can get this
and then you go to a drug store our
pharmacy that sells it that
that answers to the Drug Enforcement
Administration I want no government
involvement at all now if a private
pharmacy says I'm not going to
distribute these classes of drugs
without a prescription from a doctor
then that's great I mean that's how a
private society works but otherwise
leave government out of it entirely
there's absolutely no reason why you
should have to go get government
permission for medication what a
marriage equality should any two people
who want to get married be able to get
married of course but government should
play no role in marriage it should be an
entirely private thing a religious thing
or a secular thing or something you
don't need government there's a
money-making operation no marriage
licenses they make money off the deal
just like their whole license your
scheme licensers from doctors and
lawyers and shoeshine people and
hairdressers just a big racket get rid
of government out of a get government
out of the marriage business just like
I'm saying could govern out of the
health care industry the monetary
industry economy get government out of
all these areas and you now you're
talking about a free society you are
anti-abortion but that comes with that
doesn't necessarily indicate what kinds
of policies you would pursue as
president what's your stance on abortion
well I'm a Catholic and therefore I
believe that life does begin at
conception and so therefore I'm pro-life
having said that I I don't put a lot of
faith in the criminal justice system to
reduce the number of abortions for one
thing it's like a murder case I mean
after you they prosecute somebody for
committing an abortion that the
abortions already committed they haven't
saved the life of that baby so I really
put my faith more in educational areas
in the Catholic Church there's something
called Project Gabriel that encourages
women to come in get counseling and help
and and then for those women that do so
out of economic reasons you know I want
a free market model economic system
where people keep everything they earn
hundred percent 100% voluntary charity
so for those women that go the abortion
route because they don't have the
finances to raise a baby that would
alleviate that sector so that's my
position so you would Dodd I mean to you
you and I've read
in various writings that you've done you
you believe abortion is murder but you
don't believe the federal government has
any say you know it just say it really
can't address that would you people like
Ron Paul and his son Rand Paul the
senator from Kentucky regularly
introduce legislation to you know
sanctity of life amendments or laws that
would say at the federal level that
abortion is a form of murder and it
should be stopped you wouldn't you
wouldn't do anything like that or you
wouldn't sign that if it came across
your desk I wouldn't sign it at all
there's no constitutional authority for
it it's just a murder case I mean we
don't want the federal government
enacting laws against murder or rape or
theft or burglary these are state crimes
leave it to the states to resolve
can I ask you as a Catholic I was raised
Catholic 50 miles from here I won't name
the parish that I'm from because I think
they're a little bit ashamed of me I'm a
lapsed Catholic or maybe a future
Catholic once again but do you believe
in did you believe in contraception or
how would you know the Catholic Church
does not believe in contraception you
know other than natural means like the
rhythm method I assume if you're a good
Catholic you don't you won't you agree
with that teaching but then what you
know should the state have any rules
against contraception or at what level
should that be decided yeah that is a
fascinating question and I've struggled
with that when I agree with you that is
the Catholic position and that is the
position I hold personally whether the
state should be empowered to stop that I
just have problems with that
I just never been able to resolve it for
myself and it's it's an issue that I've
struggled with for a long time can i
more broadly you know it's it's
fascinating in a way you mentioned John
F Kennedy or we've talked about John F
Kennedy the only Catholic president to
date when he was running for office his
his religion was a big deal and then
kind of went away and then it became a
big deal again particularly in the late
70s and 80s Jimmy Carter really you know
mainstream the idea of born-again
Christianity was a fundamentalist or an
evangelical Ronald Reagan played to the
religious right in order to gain office
and things like that
how does sure how does your Catholicism
inform your libertarianism and your
politics or are these separate realms
yeah that's a fascinating question very
profound I find my religion and I'm a
devout Catholic totally consistent with
my libertarianism and it's and this is
what a lot of Catholics I mean I I find
it amazing I go to church Nick sometimes
and and I hear them praying for the
troops in Iraq or whatever I'm sitting
there thinking if sometimes I write a
letter to the priests saying why aren't
we praying for the people killing these
people and we never pray for the victims
and it's it's just phenomenal to me
you've got people Christians supporting
sanctions against Iran that's killing
all these innocent people are used to it
like in Iraq where they the sanctions
bill the hundreds of thousands of Iraqi
children and I don't see this this thing
is a matter of conscience for Christians
and that's what I would hope to bring to
this race if I win this nomination among
the Christians in this country is look
you know you've got a conscience here
you need to start exercising it and that
conscience means sometimes standing up
against the wrongdoing of your own
government but in terms of things like
free will
it's totally consistent with the
non-aggression principle you have a law
a way you have the right to live your
life any way you choose so long as your
conduct is peaceful non-fraudulent no
force well that's what freewill is all
about God ves man with free will like on
charity this is why I opposed Social
Security and Medicare in these welfare
state programs god this man with the
right to choose whether to honor mother
and father on your on a voluntary basis
he wants you to but he doesn't force you
to well and with Social Security you're
forced to with Medicare you're forced to
that's a denigration of god's great gift
of free will
so all right that's what I would hope to
bring to this campaign is striking
Christians with a conscience saying this
is what free
well and freedom is all about not what
we got today what is she very quickly
what is your take on Pope Francis in a
way and again I say this I you know as a
lapsed Catholic but as somebody who
follows him with follows the Catholic
Church in the papacy with some interest
on a certain level he seems to approach
the imitation of Christ that the Pope is
supposed to be he you know he he mingles
with the poor and people with leprosy
and things like that and he seems to
have great compassion he also seems to
be a very outspoken critic of capitalism
and the Catholic Church really since the
mid 19th century you know turned against
modernity in many ways they didn't like
democracy they didn't like capitalism
they didn't like equality of men and
women you know as Pope Francis a force
for good or bad do you think in the in
the world today well I think overall a
force for good I mean obviously the man
is very very devout man of God loves the
poor that the needy is just like many
leftists and he's a leftist politically
ideologically they they don't see any
problems with turning to the state to
accomplish these things and and this is
a I mean this is just his philosophy his
leftist philosophy but there are strands
of free-market libertarianism within the
church where annavaram is is they you
know almost a capitalist Creed and I
think if some of these you know devout
Catholics including the Pope could ever
just look at libertarianism and see that
this is consistent with free will and
and the right of people to choose
between right and wrong as long as his
peaceful conduct no murder rape and
theft the charity should be entirely
voluntary I think they would take a
different look at it as a final live two
final questions the first one is this if
you win the lp nomination you will be
seventy years old so you'll be the
youngest of the three major party
candidates running but you're still
pretty old okay what is your message to
young people because when I think it I I
have two sons 28 and 16 they have grown
up in a world
of 911 of the financial crisis of the
coronavirus lockdown now you know what
you know it's kind of bleak it's kind of
screwed up and I say that as somebody
like you and I was born in 63 so I
caught the tail end of the baby boom and
of the Vietnam War and all of that kind
of stuff things were bad but things are
really screwed up now as a 70 year old
man you you have to benefit of being
partly part Hispanic because of your
heritage so you look like the future of
America which is multi-ethnic you know
kind of free thinking and
individualistic what is what's your
message to young America why should they
be libertarian and why should they vote
for you well it's interesting you say
that because young people would be one
of the target audiences I would I would
target in this campaign and my message
is I trust you I trust you with your
freedom right now the government's taken
out of your paycheck two trillion
dollars a year just for Medicare and
Social Security and what they're saying
to you with taking this money out of
your paycheck is you're a bad people you
cannot be trusted to handle your own
money that you'll turn your backs on
your parents you'll turn your backs on
the needy I'm saying bull
keep your money cut out the middleman
the IRS and these and social socialist
administration's I trust you to handle
this on your own God trusts you who is
the state to take away that trusted God
places in you with free will but the
problem that's not the problem here the
problem is you have to start believing
in yourself you have to get self-esteem
you got to say we can handle this will
on her mother and father on a voluntary
basis we'll donate to the poor on a
voluntary basis you got to believe in
yourself you got to believe in others
you got to believe in free will you got
to believe in freedom and for me you got
to believe in God and that would be my
primary message to them which is very
different from some of my libertarian
opponents they say oh no you can't you
need a you needed this course you've set
a system here because young people can't
be trusted and in England let me give
you an example of this in England the
government call for two hundred and
fifty thousand young people to volunteer
to help out seniors who are under
lockdown they couldn't get their gross
médecins 750 thousand young people
volunteered overnight that's the kind of
society I want for America and then the
final question is what is your you know
the LP has had in Gary Johnson and ran
in 2012 in 2016 he had a lot of critics
because he was in a purist you're very
much a purist but Gary Johnson did
phenomenally well relatively speaking
for the Libertarian Party what do you
expect if you can win the nomination you
know what what kind of outcome do you
expect realistically and you know will
it be an improvement on the numbers that
Gary Johnson put up in 2016 and 2012
impossible to say but I mean we've been
here 49 years nick is a party and we
celebrate a 3% return I mean I just
think that's kind of sad we've never
elected somebody to Congress I say this
time around this this movement 70 years
old this time around let's not settle
for what's practical and you know reform
this and reform Medicare reform Social
Security and scared of how people are
gonna react let's do something bold
let's go all in and have a campaign of
pure principle when we fight with just
the return principles and go to the
American people who right now are doing
some serious soul-searching there's
nothing like the prospect of death to
cause people to do some self-examination
and say this is what a free society is
it's the absence of a welfare state it's
the absence of a national security state
see absence immigration and trade
restrictions is the absence of drug war
and central planning and make the case
to them in a principled way because when
you make the case to people on programs
that are Republican or Democrats that
are not libertarian you may get a large
vote total but what have you
accomplished the only way to achieve
freedom is by making that case for
freedom to Americans they may reject it
but it's the only chance you have but
I've learned in life man when you act
with boldness you got a chance for a big
payoff when you play it safe you don't
have a chance for a play a big payoff
you're gonna get maybe three four
percent you act boldly and you bill
after Donald Trump and and and Joe Biden
and their Democrat Republican cohorts
with principles ideals and ideas on
Liberty you got the possibility of a big
payoff and after 49 years we've earned
the right to a big payoff and then your
vote totals are meaningful because
people know up front exactly what you're
trying to do when they join you they're
joining you for the right reason all
right well that is the ultimate zag when
people are zigging we're gonna leave it
there Jacob Hornberger thank you for
talking to reason I appreciate it very
much
my priest my appreciation is Nick thank
you so much for having me